[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
esta vez escala en parís se adentra en
el sinuoso camino de las relaciones
diplomáticas entre eeuu y cuba pero
también vamos a hablar del proceso de
transformación que se está viviendo en
la isla y de lo que ha sucedido en
materia de la pandemia de lakovic para
hablar de ello contamos aquí en nuestros
estudios con la presencia de el
embajador de cuba helio eduardo
rodríguez embajador bienvenido muchas
gracias
es usted embajador de la república de
cuba ante francia quiero comenzar con lo
que puede ser una muy buena noticia para
el público que nos sigue y es el proceso
de investigación que viene desarrollando
la isla de cuba desde el año pasado para
encontrar una vacuna precisamente que
pueda combatir la pobreza yo sé que hay
tres que están en proceso de
investigación pero me gustaría centrarme
en la que está más adelantada que es
precisamente soberana 2 este mes de
marzo va a entrar en la tercera fase ya
de pruebas de manera muy breve de qué se
trata y cuándo podría empezar a
funcionar si es que funciona esta vacuna
bueno en efecto como sabe hemos
invertido mucho en los últimos 60 años
en lo que se refiere a la investigación
científica en cuba en cuba producimos 8
de las 11 vacunas que se utilizan para
vacunar a nuestra población desde el
inicio de la pandemia nuestro centro de
investigación trabajaron fuertemente en
la producción de candidatos vacunales
tenemos hoy 5 candidatos vacunales de
ellos como bien mencionó uno en fase más
avanzada soberana 2 que acaba de entrar
este mes en la fase tercera de ensayos
clínicos
alrededor de 40.000 personas van a
recibir la vacuna durante este mes
nosotros estamos muy optimistas con los
resultados experimentados hasta ahora
con los diferentes candidatos vacunales
pensamos que estaremos en capacidad este
año de vacunar a toda la población
cubana inmunizar a toda la población y
humanas 12 aproximadamente casi 12
millones de habitantes y tenemos
previsto poder producir durante el año
100 millones de dosis de vacunas en el
país lo cual nos permitirá por supuesto
vacunar a toda nuestra población y estar
en capacidad de cooperar también con
otras naciones
100 millones sin duda alguna es un
objetivo muy ambicioso dado el plazo en
los que estamos y además las
limitaciones que existen en cuba en
materia de embargo del cual hablaremos
pero como van a hacer al mismo tiempo
sabemos embajador que hay hoy en día un
problema de medicamentos en la isla hay
un problema en las farmacias de escasez
de medicamentos como van a ser ustedes
para fabricar esos 100 millones que se
requieren de jeringas requieren de bases
especiales y sabemos que hay un problema
de abasto en este terreno el país ha
tenido que hacer un gran esfuerzo en una
situación económica muy complicada muy
difícil tuvimos cuatro años de
administración trump después seguramente
mencionaremos el tema con una política
es muy agresiva hacia cuba se reforzó la
aplicación del bloqueo económico
comercial y financiero con un impacto
económico esencial en cuba' en casi 60
años cuba ha perdido por el impacto del
bloqueo 144 mil millones de dólares más
de 5 mil 500 millones de dólares anuales
producto del impacto del bloqueo en
todos los sectores de la economía
también afecta el sector de la salud
pero realmente hemos concentrado los
recursos en el enfrentamiento a la
pandemia hemos concentrado los
principales recursos en el apoyo a la
investigación para estar en capacidad
e inmunizar a toda nuestra población
este año con nuestra propia vacuna lo
cual sin duda será un gran logro para
que esto se pueda probar para que ésta
una soberana 2 pueda llegar a su fase
final se requieren pruebas evidentemente
va haber un test con la población de la
habana sintiendo bien pero la banda es
una población pequeña con respecto a lo
que se requiere como test general
entiendo que hay otros países que
podrían participar de la parte de
pruebas a este respecto en efecto a
otras naciones nos han planteado la
disposición de participar también en la
fase 3 de ensayos clínicos existe una
cooperación con el instituto pasteur de
irán también con méxico se trabaja en
ese sentido nosotros estamos avanzando
con la población cubana disponible para
ellos y también estamos en capacidad de
hacer avanzar los ensayos clínicos en
otros países que así lo soliciten
lo decía usted de embajador hay
problemas
lo sabemos históricamente cuando eeuu
del triunfo de la revolución de 1959 en
enero pasado antes de dejar el gobierno
el presidente de eeuu donald trump
decidió volver a poner a la isla de cuba
dentro de la lista de países
promueven el terrorismo la razón fue que
el gobierno de cuba se negaba a
dijéramos enviar a la delegación del
ejército de liberación nacional que
estaba en negociaciones a bogotá bien
más allá de la irregularidad de este
procedimiento concretamente qué
significa para cuba estar de nueva
cuenta hoy en la lista de países que
promueven el terrorismo y por lo que la
primera vez fue con el presidente ronald
reagan y es duro de 1982 hasta el 2015
cuáles son los efectos prácticos de dos
ejemplos de lo que esto significa bueno
con la administración tramos se tomaron
más de 240 medidas ejecutivas para
reforzar la política contra cuba en
todos los sectores del orden político
diplomático económico comercial
financiero y esta fue la última medida
la inclusión de inclusión de cuba en la
lista de estados llamados patrocinadores
del terrorismo nosotros rechazamos el
derecho el de eeuu incluirán a cualquier
país en una lista los rechazamos con un
contundente plantear completamente
ilegalmente y lo otro es que no existe
ningún basamento para esos cubos ha sido
víctimas
y durante 60 años hay 3.400 cubanos que
han muerto por acciones terroristas
organizadas desde eeuu hay más de 2.000
personas que han resultado mutilados por
acciones terroristas nosotros hemos sido
víctimas del terrorismo y cuba siempre
ha sido un país que se ha manifestado
contra el terrorismo en todas sus formas
y manifestaciones
el objetivo es precisamente impedir que
la nueva administración demócrata en la
presidencia vaya a hacer un cambio de
política ya que va en esa dirección esta
medida tomada por la administración
dificultad es un proceso un evento el
proceso de avance en las relaciones con
cuba bajo esta nueva administración y
por supuesto hacer cada vez más difícil
la vida en cuba está de este tipo de
medida tiene un impacto en el
relacionamiento de cuba con el mundo en
los negocios en las canciones económicas
financieras e intenta no promover o
desestimular las inversiones extranjeras
en cuba incluso el turismo en fin trata
de utilizarse como un instrumento más
para afectar el buen desenvolvimiento de
la economía cubana inversiones
extranjeras caída del turismo esto lleva
entre otras cosas a que el año pasado
las limitaciones que han puesto el
régimen de don alto en el gobierno de
donald trump si sumamos el cierre de la
isla por el cob y si sumamos los efectos
de la ley de importación de
exportaciones también por esta pandemia
el año pasado perdió 11 por ciento del
producto interno bruto si lo quiero
comparar esto vale equivale más o menos
a lo que se vivió durante el llamado
período especial de 1989 cuando se
perdió 33 por ciento en tres años claro
está proporcionalmente es tan fuerte
como eso como va a ser ahora uva
precisamente para intentar salir de esta
situación cuando como usted dice quieren
producir 100 millones de dosis de
vacunas cuando hay las limitaciones en
farmacias para medicamentos y demás
bueno estamos haciendo un gran esfuerzo
seguimos haciendo un gran esfuerzo desde
el punto de vista de la política interna
estamos tomando medidas económicas
esenciales para hacer más eficiente a
nuestra economía se acaban de
implementar decisiones fundamentales
como ellos la unificación monetaria y
cambiaria se acaba de decidir una
importante reforma salarial en cuba se
ha multiplicado por 5 la masa del
salario de la población cubana estamos
haciendo grandes esfuerzos por controlar
la inflación evitar una subida y no
controlada de los precios
y sobre todo estamos trabajando también
por promover una mayor producción
agrícola una producción agrícola más
eficiente es fundamental para cuba ser
más autosuficientes del punto de vista
agrícola hacer la apertura al mercado
privado y en ese sentido estamos dando
más participación a el llamado trabajo
por cuenta propia y el trabajo título
privado que tiene un espacio entre la
economía cubana lo ha tenido ya en el
pasado alrededor de 700.000 personas
trabajan hoy en lo privado y pensamos
que hemos dando cada vez mayor existen
las condiciones para dar más
oportunidades también al sector privado
participan ya en el desarrollo de los
programas económicos de cubos
ciertamente usted lo decía a partir de
enero pasado el gobierno que dirige el
presidente díaz canel ha aplicado una
reforma monetaria no sólo monetaria que
económica de manera general se ha
unificado el cv que era el peso
convertibles y el kun que era el peso
cubano se ha fijado una paridad de 24
unidades para
como usted lo decía se aumenta el
salario mínimo a 2100 pesos si no mal
recuerdo algo así como 87 dólares hoy en
día asimismo se incrementan las
pensiones en fin pero igual hay un
problema de inflación que se está
viviendo en la isla yo doy dos ejemplos
me gustaría que usted seguramente usted
conoce mucho más tengo el caso de un
jubilado que hablaba por nosotros que
nos decía el transporte la banda me
cuesta 40 centavos el autobús hoy me
cuesta dos pesos el pan que me costaba
cinco centavos hoy me cuesta un peso no
hay el riesgo de que haya una explosión
por esta situación
la realidad es que los precios en
cubanos serían desde hacía mucho
ciertamente el transporte costaba 40
sentados de hacía 30 años el pan tenía
ese valor de hash y aproximadamente el
mismo perder un símbolo de igualdad era
un símbolo de igualdad entonces nosotros
el principio básico es mantener el
acceso de los cubanos a lo que es
esencial
todas estas reformas no han tocado para
nada la gratuidad en los servicios de
educación en los servicios de salud en
la seguridad social se mantiene todas
las ventajas en ese sector pero la
economía del país en estos momentos
demanda cambios actualizaciones no es
posible mantener los mismos costos o los
mismos precios de servicios como lo que
existían hace 30 años hay que actualizar
eso se ha hecho un incremento salarial
de explicó en sentido nc se multiplicó
por 5 la masa salarial y también ha
habido un incremento de los precios
porque hay que adaptarlos a los tiempos
actuales de todas maneras las medidas
que se han tomado se están revisando le
pongo un ejemplo se aplicó una primera
tarifa del precio de la electricidad se
demostró y hubo criterios de la
población de que era alta muy alta y
hubo que revisar esa decisión y bajar la
tarifa de electricidad a un precio más
razonable un costo más razonable y las
autoridades han planteado la disposición
en contacto y diálogo permanente con la
población a ir ajustando las medidas que
se han tomado para perfeccionar este
proceso y que tenga lo que se cumple el
objetivo real que es mejorar
la vida de los cubanos mejorar su
capacidad adquisitiva y al mismo tiempo
hacer que la economía funcione mejor con
una moneda con una tasa de cambio bien
clara que estimule la eficiencia la
eficiencia del trabajo que estimula la
productiva de trabajo y que permita a
los mecanismos productivos cubanos
funcionan de una manera mejor para
mejorar eso hay liberalización del
mercado liberalización del sentido que
se trasladarán actividades que
controlaba el estado y el sector privado
más de 2.000 actividades en general el
estado va a conservar 124 actividades
pero uno de los objetivos centrales es
que a corto plazo como a mediano más
tardar es decir en dos años cuando mucho
la libreta de razonamiento el
racionamiento desaparezca si entiendo
bien entonces el problema es cómo
compensar lo que antes era cierto un
reflejo de la penuria que existía pero
que distribuía a todo el mundo de manera
más o menos igual ahora a una situación
donde cada quien puede pensar
dependiendo de los pesos que tenga podrá
comprar en realidad para nosotros lo
esencial es seguir distribuyendo lo más
equitativamente posible la riqueza en
cuba' la poca riqueza que existe
mientras la economía vaya mejorando
se irá distribuyendo más como es lógico
la libreta de racionamiento estará hasta
que sea necesario para garantizar que
ningún cubano deje de recibir lo que es
esencial para la vida esa es la política
y mantendremos los instrumentos
necesarios los mecanismos necesarios
para seguir aseguran para mantener la
distribución más equitativa posible de
lo que es esencial para la vida de todos
los cubanos estamos llegando ya al final
de esta entrevista con el embajador de
cuba helio eduardo rodríguez
representante de la república de cuba
entre el gobierno de francia
evidentemente nos quedan muchos temas
por tratar no me queda sino agradecerle
usted su presencia señor embajador
muchísimas gracias gracias a ustedes por
la invitación a ustedes les damos
también las gracias por su asistencia y
les invitamos a una nueva escala en
parís la próxima semana
[Música]